you directed an episode that the episode
that airs tonight yeah I did and this
episode tonight is a little different
because it's more political broad city
is not really a political show you do
you to do such a great job of exploring
just sort of little distant different
social mores and stuff that's going on
as two women wandering on the city you
don't really tackle politics but you did
in this episode yeah I think the
politics of the show I've always just
sort of been behind the scenes just like
kind of how these two live their lives
can be seen as political but yeah this
one is is definitely a little bit more
heavy-handed I'm so proud of this
episode is the first episode
it's yeah so you know the plot what's
the plot yes not show in a nutshell
quick little nutshell so it gets
Solana's storyline it's as a spoiler but
it's 11 so you've all seen it you've
just watched it yeah exactly so I want a
storyline is she's having trouble
orgasming mm-hmm and she doesn't know
what's I know I think she just orgasm
she doesn't know what's going on and she
goes to see this sex therapist based on
this famous sex therapist Betty Dodson
we based it on her and throughout the
throughout the course of the episode we
realized that it she hasn't can I say
she has I'll just keep with orgasm she
hasn't orgasms since the election and
since Trump was elected she has not had
an orgasm yeah and she doesn't know she
has doesn't realize I don't know what's
going on she kind of like comes as
realization through the therapy and you
know we we never like to sit down in the
writers room and were like you know what
we have all these are the things we want
to say it's not like we really were like
we we need to focus on politics at all
but we were just talking about it so
much and we had this hiatus between when
we originally wrote and the election
happened and then we came back and we it
was just on our minds everyone in the
room
and I are just constantly talking about
him and what's going on and our
frustrations and so it sort of
organically seeped in and this felt like
an appropriate way to to comment on how
we were feeling I don't know about you
but I was all the time
[Applause]
constant it's like I got the hiccups why
you have the desk yeah yeah no I just
don't I don't think everyone I don't
think anyone was really feeling super
horny right right post-election yeah
well I think about 28% of the yeah we
haven't live here from a different
episode and I believe in this clip a
different episode of broad city I think
this is not the political this is oh my
god this is the most confusing night of
all time let's try that yeah this is
yeah you'll see this is Alana with the
therapist played by Marcella Lowry who's
you you'll know her she's been in
everything she's your rific let's take a
look this clip from broad city
so then what seems to be your problem
today it's not my problem it is my
friend
Abby's problems I'm just here for her by
proxy
she hasn't orgasmed in months and she's
too embarrassed lol here to see you I
just want to help her be a queen like
her best friend me is so your friend
hasn't been months and you're here for
her
exactly
okay if that's what you want to do
[Applause]
you